Bonjour à toutes et à tous, aujourd'hui
nous allons parler un peu des glaciers.
Vous savez, ces très gros glaçons qui
recouvrent des continents entiers, pour
une surface équivalente à 30 fois la
France. Tout de suite, ça jette un froid !
Ces glaciers sont confrontés au réchauffement
climatique qui affecte la température des
courants marins et de l'air, notamment sous
l'effet des tristement célèbres gaz à effet deserre.
- Mouais... Moi je sens pas une si grande différencede température que ça, hein.
-Ah bah, quand même, attends,
l'année dernière, en Arctique, il faisait 4,7
degrés plus chaud que ce qu'on avait observé en
moyenne pour la fin du XXème siècle. Du coup, lesglaciers fondent à grande vitesse.
-Gnagnagna les ours polaires
qu'ont plus d'banquises... Ben moi,
tant qu'il me reste des glaçons dans mon Chardonnay,
j'veux rien savoir.
-Euh, ouais, le souci, c'estqu'on voit arriver de sérieux ennuis à cause de
la fonte des glaces. Et en premier lieu, la montéedes eaux. Rendez-vous compte qu'en France, les côtes
sableuses de la Nouvelle Aquitaine reculent jusqu'à2 mètres par an. D'ici 2050 la mer pourrait avoir
gagné 50 m sur la terre. De quoi faire barboterle phare des baleines sur l'île de Ré.
-Ah, non, hein !
Pas l'île de Ré ! Attends, où je vais passer mesvacances, moi ? Bon, c'est à qui qu'il faut donner
du pognon pour sauver la banquise, les ourspolaires, tout ça ?
On s'en sortira pas avec des
actions ponctuelles. Pour mieux lutter contre le
phénomène, il faut l'appréhender en profondeur.
Pour cela, direction 200 mètres sous terre, sous le
glacier d'Argentière, près de Chamonix. Ce géant de
19 kilomètres carrés perd un mètre d'épaisseurchaque année depuis 30 ans. Nous sommes dans un
souterrain arpenté par une équipe de chercheursdu CNRS pas comme les autres : des glaciologues.
-Boah, facile hein. Moi aussi j'suis glaciologue, je connais
tous les parfums : chocolat, noix de macadamia...
-Mais non, la glaciologie c'est la science des glaciers!
Et ça demande aux spécialistes d'être très au fait
des propriétés physiques de la glace, pourcomprendre comment elle se forme et se
transforme. Mais ça exige aussi d'être un très bontopographe pour mesurer les mouvements du glacier,
parce qu'il faut pas croire, mais les glaciers,ça bouge beaucoup ! Rendez-vous compte que la
vitesse de déplacement des glaciers alpins est del'ordre de 40 m par an. Comment le sait-on ? Grâce à
une bicyclette ! Vous voyez, cette roue de vélo, elletourne depuis 1972. Le Professeur Robert Vivian
a eu l'idée de l'installer sous le glacier, pourmesurer comment il se déplace à l'horizontale
et à la verticale. Toute la journée et toute
l'année, depuis plus de 30 ans, la roue court sur
le glacier, suivant le moindre de ses frémissementset répercutant les déplacements le long d'un bras
qui envoie toutes les informations dans un cavitomètre : "Une roue en contact avec la glace.
Le cavitomètre enregistre le glissement duglacier sur le lit rocheux, et les mouvements
verticaux de la boule."
- Oh bah, facile, hein ! Moi aussi
j'suis cavitomètre. Là je rentre en voiture, là je
rentre à vélo, et là je rentre pas.
-Les chercheursont aussi posé une caméra pour visualiser le mouvement
du glacier vu de dessous, et quand on accélèrel'image, le résultat est assez impressionnant.
Vous trouvez ça badass ? Vous n'avez encore rienvu. Le glacier d'Argentière est le seul glacier
au monde à être sur écoute : le tout grâce à unemission digne de James Bond baptisée Resolve.
-Euh, ils ont que ça à faire de mettre un glacier sur écoute?
Comme si ça causait, un glacier !
-Eh ben, oui, en quelques sortes !
En se déplaçant sur le sol rocheux, le glacierémet un bruissement, et en l'enregistrant
les chercheurs vont pouvoir comprendre à quellevitesse, et selon quelles dynamiques, le glacier
se déplace. Pour cela, 12 capteurs sismiques ont été
installés à la base du glacier. Ils ont enregistré
non-stop toutes les vibrations pendant un mois.
Les douze capteurs souterrains sont accompagnés
de 100 capteurs disposés en surface, à 2500 mètresd'altitude, s'il vous plaît. Et il vaut mieux être
prêt à mouiller la combi de ski, parce que
deux heures d'ascension seront nécessaires
pour atteindre le haut du glacier.
"Quand te reverraiiiis-je, pays merveilleux !"
"Où ceux qui s'aimeeent, vivent à deuuux" !"
En surface, un capteur est posé tous les 50 mètres, pour créer un
maillage de mouchards assez dense. Pour créer uneréférence d'ondes perçues, les chercheurs ont apporté
un drôle d'objet : regardez cette lourde cloche.
-Çava alors l'autre depuis qu'elle fait de la science
Elle permet de créer des sources sismique
artificielles. En tapant dessus et en enregistrant
à intervalles réguliers, les chercheurs se
dotent de points de repère, en observant les
courbes créées par les gongs sur les relevéssismiques. La conclusion de tout cette étude,
c'est que ce glacier glisse de moins en moinsvite avec le temps, ce qui n'est pas une très
bonne nouvelle, parce que s'il ralentit, c'est parcequ'il est moins lourd, parce qu'il fond. Logique.
Alors comment éviter d'essuyer un naufrage à lamode Titanic, mais sans l'iceberg, vu qu'il aura
fondu, dans les prochaines décennies ? Eh bientout d'abord, nous devons poursuivre nos efforts
pour réduire la production de gaz à effet de
serre grâce à nos gestes écologiques quotidiens.
Mais il nous faudra sans doute aussi rendre
les zones littorales plus sûres, grâce à divers
aménagements architecturaux, comme les digues parexemple, permettant de réduire l'avancée de la mer
vers nos habitations. Sinon, après les masques,on risque d'être obligés de porter des bottes
chez nous, et ça c'est pas terrible.
Voilà, c'esttout pour cet épisode un peu glaçant, mais on
vous dit à très bientôt pour un prochain épisoded''Un Zeste pour la Planète", et d'ici là, offrez-nous
du like, du partage et surtout abonnez-vous!